If you're graduating right now or you've
just graduated,
I would make a very simple observation.
Okay.
Because I think you're very lucky to be
graduating now because 25 years ago when
people graduated and went,
let's say,
had a job in investment banking and very
successful careers at,
let's say today they're in their middle
to late fifties and they've just retired
and you meet them at a cocktail party.
What do they tell you about
CEO of an investment bank?
They tell you about the peace corps
years and what they did in the Peace
Corps.
I'm saying,
wait a minute,
you've just had this amazing life and
you're talking about the peace corps.
And then they say,
yeah,
and now I'm going to use the rest of my
life to do something meaningful,
made a lot of money,
and my kids are graduated empty nest and
I now I'm going to do something
meaningful.
And I say to myself,
wow,
here's somebody who graduated and
basically did something meaningless for
a period of time and then decided to do
something meaningful.
And the reason I'm so enthusiastic about
people who graduate today is that we're
starting to understand that it's
possible to have meaningful lives all
the way along and to be a social
entrepreneur.
If you want to put your entrepreneurial
energy in that way,
to do things that in fact do mix market
with mission.
It's in fact a period today where you
can take an avocation and turn it into
something that's very intimately
connected with what you do and if you
are,
you know,
toying with taking a job because it pays
well but you hate it,
don't do that.
Don't ever do that because it is be the
saddest peer.
You're going to wake up every morning
unless you really wake up and not only
smile about it,
but you tell your spouse or your family
what happened.
Then how excited you are.
That's the life you want to live in more
than ever before.
Lots and lots of people can do that and
so that's why I think graduating today
would be really interesting.
30 years ago,
we were a bit more in lockstep,
obedience,
and you did things because you were
supposed to,
an opportunity didn't include making the
world a better.